When you meet other game developers
They realize how enthusiastic they are
And their passion
Seeking to participate
What you know and inspired
new ideas.
There is a big difference between enjoying the games
And manufacturing.
It requires learning a lot
And made a great effort
And continuous work on
The game itself for a long time
And learning programming techniques.
Not only do you imagine the game
And enjoy it.
My name is Gerald Tok
I am the CEO of Inzen Studio
In Singapore.
Dark Dot is a special game.
The pool is between
Traditional shooting games
But instead of fast movement
The movement made us slower
Via adding a tactical element
The method uses a shape change.
On Independent Game Developers Day
We learned to connect our thoughts
With data
And learn how
User interaction
With changes.
Analytics has helped us recently
On the test card
New store data
The number of game downloads increased
By 25 percent.
We are fully acquainted with
Platform features
We were able to interact more
With players.
We have now registered more than 200 thousand
Download new and get us
Editor's Choice Award.
My name is Yogi Aditya
I am a technology officer at Niji Games
In Yogyakarta.
Our goal was innovation
Game puzzles distinct.
That was the most important.
After several months, we invented
Game we enjoy playing
We launched it on Google Play.
Cute Munchies
The admiration of everyone.
I upgraded the number of downloads and got the
5 star ratings, but did not last
Users in play.
Google taught us how to urge
Users to play more
For a longer period.
Google explained to us how to apply
The feature saves the progress level of the game
And Google Play Games services.
We tried to improve
Store data cards and icons
Downloads increased by
93 percent well and profits
By 51 percent.
The retention rate has improved
Since the first week.
Now we think about the future
And by creating games
more developed.
My name is Vinh Nguyen
I create games with my friends
For V-Games in Vietnam.
Game innovation took
Gungun two years.
We were inventing the game that
We wanted to play it.
But in the end
We have not made any profits.
We thought of innovation
Another game, however
We were relieved of failure.
We decided to keep trying
We did not accept failure.
We met a Google consultant
He told us that our game was fantastic
But we have made it in a way
Ensures profitability.
We've added a bundle for premium users
To buy additional features and let us buy
Mobile vehicles and personalities
directly.
Our earnings have increased automatically
By 100 percent
One day.
We achieved second place
On the Play site.
The enthusiasm of our staff helps us
Always achieve
What we hope.
We have masquerade amateurs and artists
The company has a pleasant atmosphere
We draw from them
The philosophy of designing our games.
Do not worry if you are a freelance game developer
If you try and persevere
You'll find a way to succeed.
We are now players
In a larger game.
The important thing is that we are still playing.